he's running around often with a top off
or a vest on the sunburn and the heat
stroke that he would get from that would
kill him gareth timmins here i'm a
former romans commando that spent time
in afghanistan egypt somalia and just
various places around the middle east
and my book becoming the 0.1
34 lessons from the diary of a royal
marines commando recruit charts my
journey and earning the romans commando
coveted green beret today we're going to
be looking at desert warfare scenes and
judging how real they are
it's cs gas which has been widely used
in the middle east especially around the
arab spring whether you would fire it
out mortars is is another thing firing
the cs gas
and having an air burst like that would
just be like
chucking a little cap of bleach into the
sea in terms of it's effective in the
sun and trying to poison swimmers
i mean if you were breaking contact like
that you would absolutely just i would
have thought just drove in a straight
line as fast as possible to get out
there
but they seemed to veer into it just for
i think for the purposes of the film and
for the viewers really fact that they're
perfectly placed on the top uh is quite
comical really a minefield would
normally be be set out in a certain way
to either restrict movement or to
channel the enemy into a particular
point in terms of the spacing and the
mixture of mines it's just been placed
there just for the vehicle just to hit
it the empty personnel mines and
actually now banned by the geneva
convention what used to happen with
those was you you'd trigger one of the
pines uh and they'd come out the ground
at about waist level and detonate but
yeah you wouldn't normally see them on
on top like that unless they've been a
sandstorm but even still they look brand
new if you were
breaking contact or trying to get away
from the enemy in an open desert like
that with no kind of life support you've
got no urban environment no
buildings you would absolutely want to
stay in that truck unless it was
completely disabled and at that point
you had no other option but to leave it
because it was acting as a magnet for
the enemy but you certainly won't bail
for it from it if it was uh if it were
moving
it provides explosive devices that have
used in like iraq and afghanistan do
flip vehicles but whether a mine would
be able to
flip it to that extent is
is debatable but certainly the people
that were inside it would be severely
injured if not killed i'd give it a
three yeah they're in the desert they're
in military vehicles there's military
getting used but apart from that it's
very loosely based on reality i have
seven mexican police vehicles located at
the border checkpoint waiting they're
moving and forming
they're really really closed up now
before they got to the border when they
were driving in urban areas or built up
areas that kind of convoy posture would
have been perfect you want to maintain
the posture in the security and not have
vehicles come in
but as soon as i've kind of left that
and they're going now into the open
desert and open ground that would want
to really really extend the space in
the humvee is it's an awful vehicle it's
not comfortable during this now you
would close up
because you've got limited visibility
it's exaggerated there really yeah it is
it is a thing it would it would restrict
your view absolutely
i think it's realistic you would have
put out contact right contact right
which is what they do again it's good
there's like natural generalized chat in
there about the weather and and whatnot
that would happen in real life there'd
be some jokes there'd be some banter
but you would be very much focused on
the job at hand so the communication
there in terms of communicating to the
whole group is is is good it could be a
bit better but it's good
you would absolutely at all costs want
to drive through that we call it driving
through it we call it the killing zone
to stop in that or be disabled in that
would be like you worst nightmare
the sound and the impact that that round
would make on the windscreen i think
would naturally despite your training
just make you do that i think once a few
rounds a day and it massaged your
anxiety of nothing's going to come
through you would like to think that
you'd be able to get back on track and
and push through that it's just it's
chaos
it's what's called a complex attack the
first guy's got out to the left which is
what you would do it on a contact right
you would get out on the left-hand side
of the of the vehicle and use it as
cover then to try and get some rams off
if you if you had to you're always told
and trained to get out of the side
naturally that's not taking a fire so
you'd get out to cover and you can see
how they're kind of getting the weapons
into the shoulder and now they're
manipulating the doors and then you're
pushing the door and coming back onto
the stock of the weapon and stuff it's
it's really like high level stuff and
weapon manipulation and use of cover
it's it's it's absolutely superb
i wouldn't want to be under there
as a soldier because you'd have no
view whatsoever of anything that's going
off and it would be claustrophobic i can
see why she's done it unmilitary trained
but
it's not where i'd want to be you've got
to try and get away from that killing
zone somehow as soon as possible i'd
give it nine the only kind of thing that
lets it down really is the spacing when
they're going to open ground in terms of
the vehicles but apart from that
how they react the weapon manipulation
the communications
is
is really good
he's running around often with a top off
or a vest on the sunburn and the heat
stroke that he would get from that would
kill him you'd have like some kind of uh
camouflage shirt on or like a tactical
jacket like a like a thin jacket and
you'd almost certainly have body hammer
on
dependent on the sun sometimes it's it's
it's soft and it would be incredibly
difficult to move i mean granted it's
got no kit on no no body armor but it
would be incredibly difficult you're
running from side to side to evade
possible enemy fire especially if that's
coming from from behind you you'd be
running two
positions of cover rather than in a
straight line
it's
there to look like a hind uh it's
actually uh the pumas that have been
modified they've been much up to like
real soviet gunships yeah they were
introduced uh i think by the russians in
1972 so they definitely would have been
in the actual afghan
and russian war in 79-89
the biggest myth really is i think about
desert warfare films is i think the hero
journey that one takes so it's if you
look at say like rambo or or anything
like that it's it's kind of a one-man
band one person getting injected into
into a theater into a into a war zone
and in reality it's just
it's wholly not possible
that weapon system 50 kalduska it would
take it down it absolutely would and i'm
just
slightly unconvinced that there would be
a enough
rounds for it
for that amount of time sometimes you
can get one or two rounds off then you
have to start doing your stoppage drills
one person could operate that yeah would
be better with two
but one person could it's a difficult
one because everything that happens is
in the realms of possibility
uh it really is i would probably give it
a five
i think the percentage of success that
he would get from doing what he does
would be very very small call it and see
if they're friendliest in the area
lima 2 charlie
lima to charlie the radio operator has
tried to establish comes via the sat
phone it's not been successful but he's
not
give the responder opportunity to
respond we've used them before in
somalia and other places it's just a
case of sometimes moving to an elevated
position or a different location to
establish communication they are
unreliable
you would have automatically hit the
floor and gone to ground and you would
have started observing from
what we call your belt buckle from your
from a prone position the mirage effect
obviously it's a thing it's there but it
wouldn't distort the images like that
and you'd still be able to make people
out and the movement towards you it's
very relaxed they're not running they're
not shouting you'd be looking for
weapons or weapon systems as they start
to get closer
form a line
they do get into extended line which
is good tactically for this scenario but
the posture that they
get into the hostile posture getting
weapons and and getting them ready to go
into the shoulder there's an escalation
that you would want to try and avoid
seeing they're all m16 some of them have
got under some grenade launcher
attachments it's
an old
american issued weapon they'll be real
weapons with probably just magazines and
we know ammunition what are you doing
guys cover him
weapon should have been down for sure
they should have had like one of them
just put his hand up but just posing a
more peaceful kind of approach maybe
saying like the local language in terms
of a welcome
would have been would have been the
right course of action to take he walked
straight into the arc the the line of
fire of all the lads he would never do
that he would have almost certainly been
killed in that if if it would have gone
gone ugly realism i'd probably give it
about
a five or a six it's not uncommon for
people to walk into
your arc of fire or your line of fire
and just be unaware of it
in this instance you would try and
scarper away to cover in a low profile
going to ground ins straight away is is
good drills try and lower your profile
but trying to get into some form of
cover would be ideal i know it's
difficult in this scene it's it's very
open and there's there's no built-up
areas or anything like that your tactics
in this would be to if you have to
engage engage but then try and peel away
yeah it'd be a worse case scenario
[Music]
it's a mini-me that the guy's got here
which is like a key tactical team weapon
uh belt fed 5.56 ammunition but just how
he's holding it
it's up and then he holds holds the back
stock is he's he's definitely been
taught that
the drills in this as well we call it
the rate of fire the people with the
rifles the m16s are like firing single
shot which for accuracy is great a
massive thing in hollywood is all
weapons are always on automatic fully
automatic and it's it's not really
correct although the drills
are good
and slick
in this you can't get away from the fact
that it looks like actors holding
weapons
probably give it a four i think the sas
in reality would have done things
differently a lot differently i don't
think you would have engaged in
preemptive strike like that unless they
were literally coming towards you and
upon you
the dog is is clearly looking for
explosives ieds putting the in the
ground just to identify
areas to avoid but they might also be
put in the ground just to show you the
allied forces
where they can move but they would sit
down yeah when they've come across
something that they're not quite happy
with they're expecting a treat what it's
kind of all about for them it's just a
game
in terms of disorientation like the
ringing noise
alluding to like how your ears would be
absolutely yeah you might not hear
anything for for minutes uh might bush
your eardrums i mean it is realistic but
they just seem to recover too quickly
from it could be an old shell
uh an old war shell that they've that
they've used pointing really towards a
vehicle
like a vehicle ied that they've kind of
detonated there the fact that it's
actually on what looks to be like a
common trail for vehicles and stuff kind
of points to the fact that it would have
been that i think it probably might have
been a greater explosion a bigger
explosion
but it would blow them back like that
if not worse k9 error would be a factor
that you that you would factor into it
especially if you've not kind of run the
dog over that area as well
hey
how did you join this hat you could've
got us all killed
it must have triggered the bomb from
those houses it's all really good until
after the explosion there's no way that
you would be kind of up on your feet and
calling somebody out for what the what
they have or haven't missed you'd be
glued to the floor you'd be you'd be
shocked you'd be disorientated
and you'd just be scared to death
there's no way that that would
you would kind of respond in that kind
of manner and another thing that you've
got to worry about is that might just be
the first detonation
there might be a secondary explosion and
i think if if somebody has detonated
that with a command wire which is which
is what's what's happened
you would absolutely be expecting an
ambush
off the back of that because you've
actually got people watching i think
it's really realistic
up until what happens after the
explosion
and for that i'd probably give it a 7.
so the red smoke is to indicate the lz
the landing zone where you're going to
extract somebody from it's slightly
strange in this clip because it's almost
self-explanatory given that you've got
helicopters just above it so it's kind
of just thrown out there probably
visually just for the viewers of this
film it would have been
an incredibly aggressive kind of posture
now from the from the rescuing forces
they wouldn't waste any time trying to
decipher whether you've got weapons or
whether you're a friendly there's just
no time for it it's just quickly in and
out so everybody in between
them and uh extracting the
the the the us personnel would have
uh it wouldn't have been a great
experience for him
[Music]
whatsoever americans or anybody will
always go back for one of their own you
would have had guys on the ground for
weeks
days before
providing ctrs close target records of
this and establishing
patterns of life what kind of weapons
they've got what time to go to bed where
they're keeping the hostage and if they
keep moving him and that would have been
getting fed back in order to
create this
this uh this rescue attempt so the first
phase of it probably would have been the
specter gunships that you see in the the
apaches coming in followed by the ground
forces following up behind
are you marcus
you're safe marcus you're going home
what they could do is probably ask give
me a service number like what's your
service number what's your name what's
your rank and stuff like that uh
which would quickly identify him so it's
true to life right it actually happened
so uh
i've got to give it a nine or ten
got movement 12 o'clock
uh 300 meters two guys on the roof
are they armed i don't know
so these are u.s marines there's kind of
two sides to the communication at the
initial start where they're saying i've
got weapons i've got weapons
it's to identify them
as potential enemy targets but also
it gives them in a sense a free pass to
engage
if the after looking for weapons is
is the combat indicator simple question
trade you see why negative that's not
the question you asked you asked if they
were on the answer to that one is i
don't know [ __ ] armed ortega why else
would they be running around up there
no do i i don't understand
people think the chatter is is hollywood
it's unrealistic
in real life it'd be very minimal and
especially the swearing as well i think
this is probably a bit tame
in terms of what it would be like real
life
certainly the
the the immature nature of it is
definitely inaccurate
they're not really using cover well and
yeah they don't really move position in
between firing or wants to take that
first shot that should move position and
especially if it's a sniper as well
because they'll just be looking for you
just to pop back up in the same position
and they'll be on target kevlar elmer
they are effective in in
in protecting your head
it all just depends on the caliber of
bullet that the elements hit with the
angle and also
uh how close it is from leaving the
barrel to it in your element if it's a
sniper which you could argue it is from
that range and picking shots off like
that
they would have kind of a long caliber
bullet like a 7.62 long firing out of
bolt action rifle it might protect him
based on angle
but uh
if it is a sniper from that distance as
well
they would probably get in like hits it
towards the center of mass or or on the
face but it would protect them
what the viewers need to appreciate is
is that it would be incredibly
incredibly uncomfortable to to have your
head above that
knowing that somebody's
firing
because all you can really think about
is is that in not even a second you
could be in the face and you that might
be you just completely turned off so you
are
uncomfortably aware of that so yeah i
think you would be a lot further down
i mean he might have had
sand kick up from the from the round
that he wants to just get out it's
probably the right course of action in
that instance he might have had a bit of
material from his helmet if he's been
shot in the helmet and stuff so yeah i'd
give it a five just because i think the
chat is kind of unrealistic it's very
immature thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click on
the one above